Turn to the beginning of the gospel of Luke.
We're going to go through a lot of Luke and acts today.
Uh,
today.
I sort of lied on the syllabus.
You know how untrustworthy I am by now.
I sit on the syllabus that we're going to talk about Luke today and have
electron acts on Wednesday.
That's not quite true because you can't really talk about Luke without also
talking about acts.
And you can't much talk about acts that talking about Luke because they're
written by the same person,
almost no scholar doubts that they're written by the same person.
There are some scholars who actually argue that you shouldn't read them as two
volumes of the same work.
Some people even say they think acts was written a good bit after the gospel of
Luke.
Uh,
but I'm going to treat them as basically two volumes of the same work.
So part part of the lecture today,
we'll focus on acts,
but a whole lot of electrical also focus on,
uh,
I mean part of Luke but also on ax.
And the next time also,
uh,
though talking about acts,
I'll go back and talk about Luke.
Did everyone get a handout of the outline of Luke and acts?
If he might,
it doesn't get,
didn't get a handout.
Hold up your hands and uh,
we'll get the teaching fellows to hand them around.
So look at the beginning of Luke.
Since many have undertaken to sit down an orderly account.
Now,
what will orderly account mean of the events that have been fulfilled among us
just as they were handed onto us by those who are from the beginning,
I witnesses and servants of the word.
So when he tells you that he's gotten some things from handed down traditions,
accounts from eyewitnesses,
what's the first thing that that tells you about this author?
He's not an eye witness.
Precisely.
I too decided after investigating everything carefully from the very first to
write an orderly account,
they are again for you most excellent Theopolis so that you may know the truth
concerning the things about which you have been instructed.
There are several things at this prologue to the gospel of Luke tells us one of
the things,
of course it is you just noticed it's not written by someone who was there.
Some people will say that when we get to acts,
at least part of ax seems to been written by a person who was actually there
because about halfway through the book of acts he starts talking about we,
we did this and we did this rather than just Paul or other people in the third
person.
I don't believe that's the case.
I believe he may have used some kind of a written document that was used the
term we are sometimes in ancient texts.
I think sometimes a person would just insert themselves into the narrative to
give it a more directness,
but so I'm not going to teach that.
This author was an eye witness of any of the stuff that he writes about,
but certainly he's not an eye witness of the stuff that happens in the gospels
as he also says.
So that's one thing that it tells us.
This also tells us that this is a compilation of sources.
Now already when you've been working on the synoptic problem in the and how to
write an x Jesus paper,
you figured out that the gospel writers used other sources.
Some of them were written sources,
some of them were oral sources.
This is guy actually admits it up front.
So it sounds like using both written sources in oral sources.
So what's one of the written sources?
We know he used mark exactly,
and we think that there's another written source that we call queue that he may
have used.
But what does he mean by orderly account?
Does it mean that mark kind of wrote things in one order and this guy knows a
better chronological order,
a historical order?
Is he talking about I'm writing Q and account.
That's more like what actually happened when it happened.
That's the way this is sometimes been interpreted by people as we'll see today.
That's not likely,
right,
because we can even tell when this author is creatively shifting events around
for his own purposes.
So he's claiming to write an orderly account,
but if he is claiming that he's giving us a more chronologically accurate
account,
then he's wrong.
As we'll see.
Probably he doesn't even mean that probably this has no claim to historicity.
He probably just saying that the way I tell this is better than the way that
mark or Q or some other sources tell it.
He's thought about the order in which he puts it and he's thought about it,
how he wants to ride as Gospel.
This also tells you what literary form this is.
He knows he's writing something that's like other literature in the ancient
world.
So the,
the gospel of acts is not a biography,
but it could have been thought of as a life.
That's the Greek word for life is be US
wherever we get biology
B oss is uh,
could be called,
could be the name of a genre of literature that talked about some great man.
We separated from biography because it doesn't have the same kind of concerns
that a modern biography does.
So He seems like he knows that for the gospel of Luke.
Anyway,
he's riding a B oss of Jesus,
a life of Jesus and how do we know that?
Because he starts off later in the gospel with the same kind of stuff that you
would see if you rate it.
If you read a book about Augustus,
the emperor or a Plato,
the great philosopher that is,
he starts off it with narratives about a miraculous birth to telling stories
about a great man in his miraculous birth was a not uncommon way to start a life
of someone.
Then an ax.
It also looks like he knows he's writing something that would look something
like a history and we have histories also from the ancient world,
so this guy is is much more than mark.
This author is much more self conscious in setting himself forward and setting
his workup as a literary work.
It has literary form who the author list though some people would think,
well maybe this is the guy's patron.
Because often in the ancient world,
when you wrote a book,
when you started off with the dedication,
the dedication,
you didn't say dedicated to so and so what you said was,
dear Theopolis,
I'm writing this because you've asked me to set down my thoughts.
In other words,
you give a fiction.
It's a fiction that the patron,
maybe the person who supports you financially or socially or whatever,
that person has asked you to set down an account or something.
So you would start off.
Uh,
dear.
Mr. Smith,
you've asked me repeatedly when we had lunch at Morrie's,
uh,
to describe my recent trip to Africa.
So I'm writing this down at your request.
That's a dedication to your patron.
Who is the office though?
Some people say maybe he's an actually historic person.
He calls him most excellent.
The Greek word would seem to imply that this guy is a fairly high class,
or at least our author wants us to believe that he's high class.
Uh,
it's also though possible,
some people said maybe he's a fiction because Theopolis comes from two Greek
words,
meaning say Oss,
which is God and fill oss.
Beloved or friend.
So some people have said he's making up a name that sort of a,
a fictive name for any God loving are beloved by God reader.
We really don't know.
So scholars are completely at sea as far as,
is this the outfit as a real person or is he not?
So those are several things about that that um,
we need to notice.
He sets himself up as writing a history by the ancient standards of history.
But is it history by our standards of history?
And the only way to figure that out is to analyze the text itself.
So that's what we're going to do on your outline.
You have on your handout,
you have an outline of Luke and an outline of acts.
I think I'm didn't get one.
I gave mine away.
Can I have one?
Thank you Michael.
So notice how it's divided up.
First you get
the beginning of the Gospel,
which actually starts off,
um,
with the birth and childhood narratives and Jesus and John the Baptist in
chapter one.
And then in chapter three,
you get Jesus meeting,
uh,
with Jesus' relationship to John The baptist.
All of this starts off partly in Galilee,
but also partly in Judea.
The birth of John Happens to Judea.
The birth of Jesus according to Luke,
happens in Galilee.
Uh,
Luke also though has Jesus family go from Judea to Galilee for the birth.
Now that's different from Matthew.
Matthew just started off with the holy family living in Bethlehem.
Luke has the idea that this family is living in Galilee and because of a census,
the family is required to go to Bethlehem,
which is in Judea.
So the family is from Galilee,
but,
but Luke really starts the action of his Gospel,
both for John the Baptist birth and for the birth of Jesus and Judea.
That's going to be important.
Then you have starting in chapter three,
verse 23,
the beginning of Jesus's Galilean Ministry,
and that goes all the way to nine 50.
So you had the beginning of the ministry,
there's an announcement in three 23.
This is Jesus began to in the 15th year of the reign of Tiberius.
Then you have a genealogy.
Then you have the temptation story in chapter four,
and then you have uh,
Jesus's inaugural address,
which we'll talk about,
uh,
both this time and next time in chapter four verses 14 through 30 is Jesus'
first sermon.
It's very clearly Luke wants to set this up as Jesus' first sermon and we'll
talk about why later.
And then you have four 30,
one to eight 56,
the Galilean ministry proper.
That is,
this is Jesus going around Galilee,
healing people,
preaching,
teaching.
Now look in chapter nine though,
then you'd get a transition period.
All of them,
most of chapter nine is a transition from the Galilean ministry to the other
main part of Jesus's,
of Luke's a passage in the gospel,
which is Jesus,
his trip to Jerusalem,
chapter nine,
verse one.
Then Jesus called the 12 together and gave them power and authority over demons
and cure diseases.
Notice now he's not really doing the Galilean ministry anymore.
He's setting up other things to happen on a look at.
Um,
now look all the way at the end of that chapter at nine 51.
Yes,
this is a very big verse in Luke,
although,
but you'd never know it unless you had a scholar kind of pointed out to you.
Nine 51 when the days drew near for him to be taken up,
he set his face to go to Jerusalem.
What does that taken up?
Probably does that refer to Jesus' ascension into heaven does a of his
crucifixion because you put somebody up on a cross,
whatever it is.
But notice we're not even toward the end of the Gospel here.
We're only about halfway through.
We're not even halfway through the Gospel where it's still very early in the
gospel compared to what the rest of it is.
And yet,
uh,
what Luke is doing is turning your attention as a reader now to Jerusalem.
So when the days drew near for him to take an up,
he set his face to go to Jerusalem.
He sent messengers ahead of him and they go through the villages.
So all the rest of the 10 next 10 chapters,
Jesus on the road on the road,
again,
it's on the road to Jerusalem.
Now this big 10 chapter on the road trip,
Jesus is road trip to Jerusalem,
is not found in the other gospels.
It's only in Luke.
So what is it?
What does it therefore?
And then in 1945 Jesus finally gets to Jerusalem and from 1945 until the end of
Luke,
you have Jesus in Jerusalem.
Then acts starts out,
and as I've said before,
the next volume acts starts by retelling a bit of what happened at the end of
Luke.
So you know you're in the second volume of a two volume work here because he
rehashes from the at the beginning of acts.
So first you get the time from one acts one one to nine 43 I've designated as
the time before the gentiles.
The church is all a Jewish community.
They all live mainly in Judea and Jerusalem.
They worshiped together.
They even spend a lot of time in the temple and the Jewish temple.
So this is very much a Jewish organization.
The gentiles haven't been brought in.
And then you have another transition period.
Just like we had a transition period in chapter nine of Luke in chapter 10 of
acts,
you have a transition period from ten one to 1225.
So first you have the conversion of the first gentile convert.
He's a Roman Centurion Cornelius,
and you have Peter Defending his conversion of Cornelius because this is
controversial to bring someone into the church without them being circumcised at
this point,
according to Luke's narrative.
And then you have 11,
19 through 30.
Look,
look at that.
Uh,
acts 11,
19 through 30.
Now those who were scattered because of the persecution that took place over
Stephen traveled as far as Phoenicia,
Cyprus and Antioch.
And they spoke the word to know him,
but Jews.
But among them were some men from Cypress and cy Reni who on coming to Antioch
spoke to the Hellenistic also proclaiming the Lord Jesus.
Now you may have a footnote after the word Hellenistic.
Does anybody have a footnote after the word hell on us there?
And your doc?
When,
what?
What is it your footnote?
Say Greeks.
So some texts have Helen this which would be sort of Greek speaking,
Jews and other manuscripts have just the word Greeks.
And in fact,
you can even take this term Hellenistic,
uh,
to be just Greeks themselves.
So at least there's some idea that these people were speaking not just a Greek
speaking Jews,
but to also to Greeks that introduces then this,
uh,
period of the gentiles.
So you have the introduction to a predominantly gentile church in Antioch,
and that's what you get from 1119 through 30.
And then you get some persecution in Jerusalem at Vir and chapter 12 and then
you get a shift of attention from Jerusalem to Judea,
to the gentiles in 1225.
But the word of God continued to advance and gain inherence.
Then after completing their mission,
Barnabas and Saul returned to Jerusalem and brought with them John,
whose other name was mark.
And I actually think that supposed to be returned from Jerusalem to Antioch.
There's some against manuscript problems because in 13 one you have now in the
church at Antioch,
they were prophets and teachers from chapter 13 to the rest of acts.
The attention is not in Jerusalem.
They go back to Jerusalem.
Paul goes back to Jerusalem a few times and you and Paul was eventually arrested
in Jerusalem and there is a trial and there's all kinds of interesting,
exciting,
uh,
riots and things that happened in Jerusalem.
But the rest of acts,
the attention is away from Jerusalem and to the rest of the world.
The rest of,
uh,
all the way there.
And then,
so that then you had from 13 one,
you had the period called after the gentiles.
This is after gentiles had been brought into the church.
And then the focus is going to be on the gentile church for the rest of acts.
So you get,
for example,
the first missionary journey of Paul.
Then you have the Jerusalem conference and Chapter 15,
which we've talked about already.
Then you have the second Miss January journey of Paul and then the third
missionary journey of Paul.
And then you have Paul,
uh,
in Jerusalem and then arrested and taken to Rome.
And then you have Paul in Rome and ending the whole book chapter 28,
17 through 31.
Notice what's going on here.
You get Luke constructs his two volume work like this.
It starts off,
uh,
in Judea.
It keeps coming towards Jerusalem.
Jerusalem,
Jews,
many focuses you on Jerusalem through the,
through all the gospel of Luke.
And then the last week of Jesus' life in Jerusalem where he's crucified,
he's resurrected.
Where did Jesus appear to his disciples after his resurrection?
According to Matthew Galilee.
Exactly.
Did Jesus appear to any of those disciples in Jerusalem?
According to Matthew?
No.
All the appearances of Jesus,
the resurrected Jesus in Matthew Tech Plays in Galilee,
not Jerusalem.
On just the opposite of that,
at the end of act,
at the end of Luke in the beginning of acts,
Jesus tells his disciples after he ribs and several of them see him and he says,
stay in Jerusalem.
Don't go out of Jerusalem in Judea until you get the Meth,
until the Holy Spirit comes.
So they they,
and it says they stayed in Jerusalem,
the whole,
he,
Jesus appeared to his disciples for a stated period of time,
according to acts,
I think it's 40 days.
Is that right?
Something like that.
And after that period of time,
Jesus no longer appeared to his disciples.
According to acts,
he ascended to heaven.
But that whole time they stayed in Judea.
So all the appearances of Ge,
the resurrected Jesus according to Luke take place in Jerusalem.
So That's interesting.
See that he starts off in Galilee,
he ends up in Jerusalem and then act starts off again in Jerusalem and then it
goes out and find to part of the world.
It expands its vision to Antioch,
to Asia,
minor to Greece,
to Europe.
And finally Paul ends up in Rome at the end.
So this is,
there's a very schematic geographical,
a system to the way Luke has organized this two volume work.
And that's even reflected in the,
uh,
layout of the outline of the book,
which is why I wanted to give you that very simple outline.
Now let's go back and see how this is reflected in other parts.
Look at Luke's Jesus inaugural speech as put forward by Luke in chapter four of
Luke.
Now we're going to spend a lot of time talking about this because you're going
to imitate me.
When you write your exit Jesus papers.
You're going to pay really good attention to all the details of the pericope p
you know you've learned now that pericope p is just a fancy Latin word,
a Greek word for section.
It's the Greek form of section.
Both of them made something cut out and sew.
Pericope p is what we,
biblical scholars,
often tall call a little piece of text that you do in X.
Jesus.
All you want to concentrate on the details of your pericope p to try to find out
what the messages.
So whatever.
What we're gonna do with this passage for 16 through 30 now,
it would help if you also compared this,
we're not gonna do that so much right now with mark six one through six because
Luke is getting the scene from mark.
But what's going to be interesting to us is what does Luke change about the
scene he gets from mark?
What does he add to the scene he gets from mark.
You could also compare it with Matthew 1353 through 58 cause that's where
Matthew has it.
If you were to compare mark and Matthew,
what you would see is Matthew pretty much just follows mark here.
He takes this story about where he finds it in the story of Mark and he puts it
in his story at chronologically about the same place.
And he doesn't have Jesus give a long speech.
He just has him appear there and and that sort of thing.
Now notice what Luke does it.
Luke takes this text and he does a lot more with it.
So we're going to read it and talk about that.
When he came to Nazareth,
where he had been brought up,
he went to the synagogue on the Sabbath Day as was his custom.
And if you're a good exit,
you had noticed as was his custom,
might need to look up in a,
uh,
concordance to see if Luke likes that phrase
cause he does.
Uh,
he stood up and read and the scroll of the Prophet Isaiah was given to him.
He unrolled the scroll and found the place where it is written.
The spirit of the Lord is upon me because he has anointed me to bring good news
to the poor.
He has sent me to proclaim release to the captives and recovery of sight to the
blind to let the oppressed go free to proclaim the year of the Lord's favor
and he rolled up the scroll,
gave it back to the attendant and sat down.
The eyes of all in the synagogue were fixed on him.
Then he began to say that to them today,
this scripture has been fulfilled in your hearing.
All spoke well of him and were amazed at the gracious words that came from his
mouth.
They said,
is not this Joseph's son.
He said to them,
doubtless you a quote to me,
this proverb,
Dr,
cure yourself and you will say,
do here also in your hometown the things we have heard you did in Capernaum
in Capernaum.
That's interesting
because he hasn't really got to compare them yet
in Luke's Gospel
and he truly,
I tell you,
no prophet is accepted in the Prophet's hometown,
but the truth is there were many widows in Israel in the time of Elijah.
When the heaven was shut up for three years and six months,
there was a severe famine over all the land,
yet a lodge was sent to none of them except to a widow at Xero fath inside and
there was a,
there were also many lepers in Israel in the time of the Prophet Elisha,
and none of them was cleansed except name in the Syrian when they heard this.
Now notice they started out the scene.
They're all happy.
He's the hometown boy.
He's come home.
They are amazed at his teaching.
The mood changes.
Why does the mood change right there?
When they heard this all in the synagogue were filled with rage.
They got up,
drove him out of town and led him to the brow of the hill on which their town
was built so that they might hurl him off the cliff,
but he passed through the midst of them.
And went on his way.
He went down to Capernaum,
a city of Galilee and was teaching them on the Sabbath.
Notice this is when he moves to Capernaum from Nazareth.
In Luke's Gospel,
in all the synoptic gospels,
Jesus Makes Capernaum his home base in Galilee,
not his hometown of Nazareth,
but according to mark and Matthew,
it's later in the gospels that Jesus has rejected in Nazareth and makes his then
moves and makes his home in Capernaum.
Notice that Luke knows this.
Luke is giving us a clue that he knows he's taking this path,
this passage out of its context from where he found it,
because the people say,
do for us what you did in Capernaum,
implying that they think of Capernaum is his home base.
Well,
that's because by that time and mark and Matthew was his home base.
By the time he gives this speech in Nazareth,
Luke takes this passage that he finds later in mark and he moves it,
plops it down at the beginning of Jesus' Galilean Ministry.
He wants this speech to be Jesus.
His first speech,
this sermon,
Jesus first sermon.
So maybe that means that if we analyze the content of the sermon,
we can try to figure out why did Luke change the setting of the story to be at
the beginning of the ministry and then also why did he make it so much bigger?
It occupies only a few little versus in mark and Luke expands it into this whole
speech and makes this big conflict.
So let's look at several different things.
First I said,
he says as was his custom,
as we'll talk about next week,
one of the main themes of the gospel of Luke and acts is that good Jewish boys
do good Jewish things.
They'd go to synagogue,
they know their scripture,
they're circumcised,
they keep kosher,
they worship in the temple.
So Jesus also is depicted by Luke as a good Jewish boy.
We'll see next time.
And I'm going to talk about some of these themes a bit more fully in both Luke
and acts.
And I'll talk about for example,
why is it only in Luke that he tells us that Jesus,
his parents,
after he was born,
circumcised him on the eighth day like they were supposed to,
after a month,
they take them to the temple for the presentation,
all of this and Lucas and tells it this is to fulfill the t,
the scripture and the fulfill the law.
And he's referring back to Leviticus.
So Jesus,
his mother and father are good Jewish parents.
They do exactly what the law tells him to do and Jesus is a good Jewish boy.
So another clue here as was his custom,
this is like Jesus goes to this,
goes to temple every Saturday.
Uh,
look also the,
the spirit of the Lord.
He says in Verse 18,
he cites a Texas.
The spirit of the Lord is upon me because he has anointed me to bring good news
to the poor.
Again,
if you took,
if you took a concur concordance and searched all the times and Luke and acts,
when the spirit either called the Holy Spirit or sometimes just the spirit of
the spirit of God occurs,
you'll find this as one of Luke's favorite themes.
The Holy Spirit in fact,
is the main actor in the book of acts.
Jesus is the main actor in the gospel of Luke.
Jesus leaves the scene.
He kind of talks from all stage every once in a while who've talked.
Talk to Saul,
Saul,
why do you persecute me?
But Jesus is kind of saying that from off stage,
the real actor in the book of Luke is the Holy Spirit.
So again,
he's getting right at the beginning of this lecture,
this sermon,
Jesus talks about the spirit.
Notice also,
the poor,
uh,
sent me to bring good news to the poor.
He has sent me to proclaim release to the captives,
recovery of sight to the blind to let the oppressed go free.
Any of you know,
the magnific caught the song that's sung by Mary when she's told by the angel
that she's pregnant.
If you,
uh,
it,
it's,
uh,
very important liturgical piece.
I'll talk about it again next time,
a little bit more depth.
But if you go to a Catholic church or a,
an Episcopalian church,
chances are you'll say,
the magnific cut.
My soul blesses the Lord.
It's called the magnificant because,
uh,
my soul magnifies the Lord in the Latin.
The first word of the song that Mary says is Magnifi caught that is magnifies my
soul,
magnifies the Lord.
And that song that Mary says has all this stuff about God will,
that her son will lift up the poor and the oppressed God will help the poor.
He will send the rich away empty over and over again in that song by Mary.
This idea that God's going to perform this great reversal of rich and poor,
the poor will be helped and made rich.
The rich will be made poor.
The high will be sent down low,
the low will be raised up high.
So we've already seen this theme already in the gospel of Luke and now it's
right here in Jesus' first sermon.
So that's another theme.
Um,
look at verse 19 to proclaim the year of the Lord's favor.
If you're using older translation of the King James version.
Anybody else have,
what do you have for 19 to proclaim the year of the Lord's favor?
Anybody have a different translation?
Yeah.
Nope.
Yes sir.
The year acceptable to the Lord.
So a lot of translations,
uh,
the older transaction will say to proclaim the acceptable year of the Lord.
That's as we'll see.
That's another theme of Luke.
He's quoting it from scripture,
but then he incorporates it.
So for example,
uh,
there'll be a time later where I will see that at one point Jesus condemns
Jerusalem because they did not recognize the time of their visitation.
So Jesus is being there on earth represents this special time is a focus of
history on one point of time.
So again,
Jesus in his first sermon quotes this acceptable year of the Lord as being his
year.
It's the Jesus Year in Judea.
Okay.
And then another theme that you see here is what happens to Jesus first.
Jesus as he sets himself up as a profit,
right?
By quoting,
by,
by siding.
Stories about Elijah who helped the woman,
the widow's son,
Alicia.
So Elijah and Elisha are important profits for Luke,
and Jesus portrays himself as being like that.
So that's why he says,
um,
no prophet is accepted in the Prophet's hometown.
But the truth is there were many widows in Israel in the time of Elijah.
When the heavens was shut up for three years and six months,
there was severe famine,
yet Elijah was not sent to them.
Alijah wasn't sent to the Jews,
to any Jewish widows,
didn't,
weren't there Jewish widows who needed a little help to God?
Well,
yeah,
but he wasn't sent to the Jewish widows.
He was sent to a non Jewish widow,
a woman who lived in the design.
There were many lepers in Israel and the time of the Prophet Elisha,
Elisha was the,
uh,
junior profit to Elijah.
Elijah anointed,
Alicia [inaudible],
knowing him,
he gave me his mantle.
And so Elisha,
after Elijah went up in the,
in the fiery chariot,
you know the flying fiery chariot.
You've heard the story swing low,
sweet chariot coming for to take me home.
Elijah doesn't die at the end of his life,
he's swooped up in a fiery chariot into heaven and in right before that he gives
his mantle to his,
his disciple Elisha,
and then is the profit there.
Elijah also weren't there,
many Jewish lepers.
Elisha,
couldn't you take a nice Jewish Leper to heal Alicia?
No,
Jesus says
he wasn't sitting to them.
He was into Naaman the Syrian.
So I said,
when they heard this,
all this all in the synagogue were filled with rage.
And I said,
why this why?
What were they so upset with?
Now you tell me.
Why does he say they were filled with rage,
right?
Then
what?
Just say it.
Shout it out.
You know,
are there no Jewish lepers?
Elijah,
are there no Jewish widows.
why are they mad?
Cause you saying he's not there.
Yeah.
Jesus is saying I'm not here for you or at least he's saying Elijah and Elisha
were sent to gentiles,
not to Jews.
Notice what Luke has done here.
He's set up Jesus as a prophet like Elijah and Elisha.
And he said,
had Jesus himself predict that the message will go out to the gentiles.
It hasn't gone out yet to the gentiles and the gospel of Luke.
Jesus pretty much sticks with the Jews.
And in fact,
Peter has to have a revelation and acts before he will go preach to a gentile as
we'll see next time.
So the Jews,
the gentiles are not receiving the gospel yet,
but Jesus is predicting that they will.
So that's another theme here that did Lucas playing on.
But notice the other thing,
what happens when Jesus does this,
he's rejected by his own people.
So another theme of Luke and acts is true profits get rejected by their own
people.
A prophet in his own country is not accepted.
So there is,
Jesus has a great prophet like Elijah and Elisha.
He's not accepted in his own country.
He's rejected.
And the gentile mission happens after the rejection by the Jews.
That's going to be a theme that we'll see over and over and acts not so much in
the gospel of Luke,
but Jean Luke is foreshadowing the book of acts in this chapter with Jesus'
sermon.
Because Jesus himself doesn't go preach to gentiles.
You had to wait until acts to get that.
But Lucas foreshadowing the rejection of the gospel by Jews and the taking of
the Gospel to the gentiles,
that you'll then see an ax and any foreshadows it all right here in this first
sermon by Jesus.
And then the last theme that you have here is them trying to,
trying to kill Jesus.
40 says,
which that's going to foreshadow the theme all the way through that,
uh,
the Gospel,
wherever the gospel goes,
you get persecution.
When we get to acts,
you'll see this in a way that,
that just drummed it into your head.
Paul goes to of town,
he goes first to the synagogue in the town.
He preaches to the Jews in the synagogue.
They get all mad.
Uh,
some of them usually except a few of them will accept.
We'll see that as a theme in acts also.
But the majority of them don't.
They reject Paul.
They throw them out of the Paul,
they tried to stone him,
or they try to persecute him and they tried to throw him out of town.
And then Paul turns and preaches the same message to the gentiles and they
accept and they form a church.
He goes to the next town,
he does this in festival Nika,
he does it in Philippi.
He doesn't in Corinth,
he tries it in Athens,
but he's not successful because nobody pays any attention to him.
In Athens.
It's a university town.
After all,
they know better,
right?
So this theme of the profits being rejected,
and it's the rejection of the message by the Jews that causes the message then
to be taken to the gentiles.
That will play out over and over again in a,
here you again,
you get it here.
So Luke has transposed that story about Jesus preaching in Nazareth from where
he finds it in mark,
which is later in Jesus's ministry.
And he puts it at the beginning of Jesus' ministry and he packs it up with all
this other stuff.
And that should be a very good clue to you.
If you're comparing Luke with mark,
you just know this must be important.
This must be a way where we really see what this author is about.
And notice is Luke concerned about when the event in Nazareth actually
historically happened?
No,
he's even,
we can tell he's even getting it out of his source from one spot and consciously
transplant.
Bring it to another spot which tells us one thing is that he does it to him.
It's not that important chronologically when this story actually happened.
What's important to him is using this story to emphasize the theological message
that he wants to emphasize.
Now let's look at another place where Luke does this.
You have to turn to acts for this though.
Look at acts chapter 11
any questions about that before I go on?
No questions.
All I love.
Good dos.
I'll students always happy with everything I say.
Okay.
Look at chapter 11 verse 19
I already read this earlier and then I read it,
uh,
actually in another lecture.
But it's very important to see what Luke is doing now.
Those who are scattered because of the persecution that took place over.
Stephen traveled as far as Phoenicia,
Cyprus and Antioch,
and they spoke the word to no one except Jews,
but among them were some men of Cyrus and Sarine who aren't coming to Antioch.
Spoke to the healthiness also proclaiming the Lord Jesus,
that the hand of the Lord was with them,
and a great number became believers and turn to the Lord.
News of this came to the ears of the church in Jerusalem and they sent Barnabas
to Antioch.
When he came and saw the grace of God,
he rejoiced any exhorted them all to remain faithful in the Lord with steadfast
devotion,
for he was a good man,
full of the Holy Spirit and of faith with a great many blah,
blah,
blah.
Then Barnabas went to Tarsus to look for Saul,
and when he found him,
he brought him to Antioch.
So it was that for an entire year.
They met with the church and taught a great many people,
and it was an Antioch that the disciples were first called Christians.
Isn't that a nice little encapsulation?
He's in that little paragraph.
Luke,
the author,
whoever.
We still tend to call these gospel writers by these names even though we don't
believe historically this was the historical Luke,
but I'll still keep calling him Luke just for cause easier than saying the
author each time Luke takes a little paragraph in which he shifts your focus
here from the whole Jerusalem,
Judea,
Jewish oriented form of the movement and now he goes to Antioch and now you get
this Greek kind of a movement.
This predominantly in a Greek speaking city Antioch.
This is one of the things that I think that that word that you're,
that my translation translates Hellenistic that they spoke to Hellenism and
verse 20 I think that's not correct.
I think that either in the original Greek and some manuscripts have this or you
just would translate this word.
It must be that they saying they spoke to Greeks.
That is ethnic Greeks.
Why do I think this is a reference to ethnic Greeks and not just Greek speaking
Jews.
And you had to have an idea
because this isn't the first time that people,
that followers of Jesus have spoken to Greek speaking Jews.
We already have in Jerusalem.
He has already told us in the earlier part of acts that in Jerusalem there were
already Greek speaking Jews,
part of the community.
And in fact it says that uh,
Stephen himself would have,
uh,
talked with these Greek speaking Jews.
So all we already have before we get to chapter 11,
the idea that the gospel of Jesus has been taken both to Aramaic speaking Jews
and Greek speaking Jews because it's already there in Jerusalem.
So He's,
he's talking about something new happening here.
This is people not just speaking to Aramaic speaking Jews or to Greek speaking
Jews.
They're actually speaking to non Jews.
And this is the first time you get this indication in the book of acts that the
movement has now spread out from Jerusalem.
And it's also being spread to Greeks,
ethnic Greeks.
And I think by Greeks he just means gentiles.
Not just Greeks ethnically,
but anybody who wasn't a Jew is what he mainly means here.
But what's interesting is that this is kind of out of place.
So one of the things I'm arguing is that unlike this translation I just read,
which might lead you to believe that the author is telling us this is the first
time they spoke to Greek speaking Jews.
I think that the original text must've meant that this is the first time that
these people are speaking to actual non Jews.
Now it's not the first time though that people can access spoken to Non Jews,
right?
When's the first time that according to acts that people actually speak to non
Jews and preach the Gospel to non Jews and non Jews become members of the
church?
When have you read acts yet?
Cornelius?
This interior,
the Roman Centurion.
Remember I said Peter has to have a whole series of revelations on top of the
roof before he's convinced to finally go preach to a gentile and convert them.
And that plagues tastes in acts 10 but now keep your finger on acts 1119 and
flip over to acts eight one through four.
Okay.
I think I may have mentioned this already,
but let's look at a bit closer now.
Okay.
Acts Eight one through four.
This takes place right after the stoning of Stephen from Stephen.
Is that a Hebrew or Aramaic name?
No.
Does anybody know where are the or the name?
Stephen comes from.
Raise your hand.
Yes sir.
Crown.
Are you a Steven?
Nope.
You just know.
Yes,
it comes from the word Stefan Oss in Greek,
which means crown.
So notice already there are Greek speaking Jews who have Greek names in the
church and Stevens.
One of them.
In fact,
the seven deacons were appointed that we saw we could read about just right
before this and acts.
Those are appointed precisely in order according to acts to be able to minister
to the Greek speakers.
Cause some Greek speaking widows were being neglected in the distribution of,
uh,
food and funds according to the text.
So the seven deacons were appointed those seven deacons,
seven hat,
they have Greek names,
so they're Greek speaking Jews and Jerusalem already.
So this right after the stoning of Stephen,
you have this,
uh,
chapter eight and Saul approved of their killing him that day,
severe persecution began against the church in Jerusalem and all except the
apostles were scattered throughout the countryside of Judea and Sumeria.
Devout men buried Stephen and made long,
loud limitation over him.
But Saul was ravaging the church by entering house after house,
dragging off both men and women.
He committed them to prison.
Now those who were scattered after the stoning of Stephen went from place to
place proclaiming the word Phillip,
who was one of those deacons along Stephen was Philip.
That's a good Greek name,
right?
At least it's a Macedonian name named after King of Mastodon,
Phillip went down to the city of Symeria and proclaimed the messiah to them.
So then you get Philip going to Samarria and so forth and you'll have other
things happening.
But now keep your finger,
keep your head,
your finger there.
Notice if you say now,
those who were scattered went from place to place proclaiming the word flip over
without thinking anything.
Don't think anything.
Acts 1119 now those who were scattered because of the persecuted hip over
Stephen traveled as far as you see,
Luke seems to have had a source,
maybe a written source that had this message about the stoning of Stephen,
the dis,
the persecution that arose in Jerusalem,
and then the dispersal of Greek speaking followers of Jesus and they don't just
go to Samarria is Phillip did.
It actually says that they went to Phoenicia Cyprus,
Antioch Bova w speaking to no one about Jews,
but then it has this message to the Greeks and the gentiles.
In other words,
from eight chapter eight verse four it must've originally joined on to what goes
without x 11 verse 19 because you can just see this narrative stops and then it
takes up again and 1119 in that Luke took what it was a text are a source for
him that had this story that had this kind of thing.
In order,
Steven Preaches the gospel to the Jews.
They get mad at him,
they persecute him and stone him.
The persecution of stoning leads,
uh,
Steven leads to more persecution of the church in Jerusalem.
The rejection of the Gospel by the Jews.
The disciples are scattered and they go,
and who do they preach to?
The gentiles?
Haven't we seen this pattern before?
We all saw it in the very first sermon of,
of Jesus,
right?
So what,
what Luke has done is he split this thing which showed that pattern and in it he
put all the stuff that's in chapters eight,
nine,
and 10,
and the first part of 11 in between there.
Now you tell me why did Luke split a narrative and put this material in between
those two sentences.
What's in that material between eight,
nine,
10 and 11?
That was Luke wanted to insert there.
What?
Pardon Peter Preaching to
Cornelius.
The gentile.
What Luke is doing is he has a source that basically,
who are the first people to preach to gentiles.
They're anonymous according to his source.
We don't know who they are.
Just some people,
some followers of Jesus,
Greek speaking followers of Jesus who were left Jerusalem in Judea.
They traveled around different parts.
They went to the eastern Mediterranean and as they went,
they took the gospel with them.
And along the way,
they even spoke not only to Greek speaking Jews,
but they even spoke to gentiles.
That's what it is.
Sources.
Luke splits that and he,
but he doesn't want to do that first he wants to say,
well Philip went to some area and he preached to some area in some area.
So you have some area there.
And then you had this whole thing with Peter and you know the story about Peter,
he's up on the rooftop praying and uh,
this sheet with all these unclean animals with alligators and snakes and stuff.
That was somehow some Sunday school material.
I had had a sheet with alligators and snakes and stuff coming down from Peter.
So it doesn't tell us in the text that there were alligators and snakes.
It's just part of my Sunday school memory.
But they're unclean animals and he's commanded to kill them and eat them.
And he says,
I'm a good Jew.
I don't eat that.
That's not kosher.
And God,
the voice from Heaven says,
what God has cleansed,
don't you declare unclean?
The vision happens three times.
Why?
Because Peter does not want to take the message to gentiles.
Is your hand up?
Nope.
Okay.
So finally Peter is forced to take the message to gentiles by God,
by revelation.
And then you have the story of the baptism of Cornelius and his house.
The first gentile converts,
and then Peter Goes back to Jerusalem and all the people,
the Jews in Jerusalem and say,
why did you do that?
You're not supposed to bring an uncircumcised people in the church.
And Peter has to defend the whole thing.
And then finally Peter wins the argument.
And even James,
the conservative head of the church in Jerusalem says,
okay,
well God must have been including the gentiles.
Also,
Luke wants Peter to be the first person to take the message to gentiles and he
wants Peter to do so only after being compelled by God to do so.
Luke knows that the first people who took the message to gentiles were probably
just anonymous followers of Jesus because he didn't source.
It's there.
He splits that source and he puts all this stuff about Peter there because he
wants Peter to be the first and only then the others in.
In other words,
what you get there is a key to what is the entire outline of acts and look back
at acts one verse eight.
Okay,
acts one verse eight gives you in a sense the outline of acts.
Yeah,
this is Jesus about to ascend into heaven,
talking to the disciples,
right outside Jerusalem in the suburbs of Jerusalem,
but you will receive power when the Holy Spirit again,
there's that Holy Spirit important for Luke has come upon you.
You will be my witnesses in Jerusalem and all Judea and Sumeria and to the ends
of the earth.
That's exactly the way he will construct the book of acts.
Jerusalem,
Judea is the country of Jerusalem.
Symeria is actually another part here,
but you had this idea that the message is going out in concentric circles.
That's why Philip,
when he has Phillip going to some area right before Peter goes to the gentiles
with in Cornelius in chapter 10 so in chapter eight Philip goes to Sumeria and
then chapter 10 Peter Goes,
and then so the dentist and then you had the gentiles and you have Rome as where
the Gospel,
I mean where the book ends up Rome sort of representing symbolically the very
ultimate ends of the earth.
This is the whole world.
So why by looking at the details,
we can tell that Luke is not telling us what happened by chronological or
historical accuracy.
He's puts it in the,
even in the order he puts it,
even the outland his books because he wants to have this message of the Gospel
centering on Jerusalem.
That's why the whole first part of Luke centers,
and that's why it has 10 full chapters on the journey to Jerusalem.
He wants to focus your attention on Jerusalem through the Book Gospel to do the
Gospel.
But then what he does is once you're in Jerusalem,
he focuses your attention on the fact that the gospel goes beyond Jerusalem.
And in one last thing,
look at Luke 21 2127.
Yeah,
we'll unpack a lot of this much more less time when we talk about both Luke and
acts as far as what are the major thematic issues in these two.
And I'll start in again next time with this or I'll,
I'll reiterate this but just to get your thinking,
look at Luke chapter 21 Luke gets this from mark 13.
Do you remember we talked about how can we tell when mark was written because it
has this abomination of desolation being set up in the temple,
which probably refers to uh,
you know,
gonna calls.
This idea from of the uh,
profit to the temple by and tag is still fraught the epiphany's but mark Billy
was going to happen in the future probably by the Romans.
And right after that happens then in Messiah comes you have all these terrible
things happen.
Masako is using mark as his source.
Mark 13.
But notice how Luke changes it.
Verse 20 when you see Jerusalem surrounded by armies,
that's not in mark.
When you see Jerusalem surrounded by armies,
then know that its desolation has come near.
Then those in Judea must flee to the mountains.
Those inside the city must flee it for these days or vengeance.
I'm going quickly through this.
You have to read over it yourself.
Look at verse 24 they will fall by the edge of the sword so the Jews will be
defeated.
He says,
not only do you have Jerusalem surrounded by the Roman army,
but you have them defeated fall by the sword.
They will be taken away as captives among all nations.
Yes,
the Jews were taken as slaves to Rome and then they were sold off and disperse
throughout the nations as slaves and Jerusalem will be trampled on by the
gentiles until the times of the gentiles are fulfilled.
None of that was in Luke source of mark.
This tells us that Luke is writing after the destruction of Jerusalem because he
tells you it happens and even says that there's going to be a time of the
gentile domination of Jerusalem,
and if you read on,
it's only after that that you have the messiah coming on the clouds.
Then as he picks up again,
the story so knows all over Luke and acts.
We can tell by looking at his sources,
his editing procedure.
Luke was written sometime after the destruction of Jerusalem and the time he's
telling the story is here and what's that time?
The time of the gentiles.
Any questions?
See you next time.